yes do you have to play the joy of
creation it's super scary Chuck you got
a number one horror gamer on YouTube
I'll never get stained Oh anything
whenever I get scared boom dab away
that's why what do job creation we play
this a while ago but it now has a
ceremony
oh it's a little scary oh nice playing
oh okay
funky music oh hell yeah so far I am
absolutely terrified by the god I'm so
scared I'm shaking look at me
Oh what are you doing John house sorry I
was just looking for I shake yes he's
okay don't worry she just seems to use a
few me sir can you tell me your name
you guys have any chicken nuggets you
won't talk on you can't just barge into
someone's house list I ordered a 6-pack
and I got five I'm looking for chicken
next come on
hottie it just better give me one
Michael
[Music]
excuse me just what are you doing in our
home the sun's about to go down don't
think you should be here again I was
just saying that you are what happened
he's clearly like a drug addict like why
don't you just kick him out after that
ad carry the stranger - against Rome he
thanked me for convincing my parents to
let him rest in our house for a night
poorly fly collected his thoughts
okay Texican steeper spacebar to stand
set up slash to interact with objects
what's up oh hey little icky it's me
Michael I'm sleeping in a baby triple e
there are monsters around there listen
to me and grow beat those monsters
alright okay so these monsters Michael
I'm playing at this baby don't look them
too long so here's what you do Glamis
your bed still stays there the more you
staring Gary monsters the worst of be on
okay on it is cool first things first uh
Freddy the front be brown there he's at
the window
Houston side close your curtains closed
until she removes we're also getting
high then there's Bonnie ill-tempered oh
my god is by it but beckons fan next
pack you will knock on the door to let
you know there so when she's next to
your bed attend a Cleveland so you hear
Emily's okay alright you got all that is
a lot but I have a little fun great hang
in there of the little sick dance I'm
sure of it
okay well this should be easy okay easy
easy peasy lemon up here
what's up top of them on and it's very
cool I love this fan made game is
[ __ ] better-looking than the panache
game Jesus Christ impressive
like this is three shut up okay we just
got to make it to the morning no problem
no problem really good at snap games and
windows notice me at the snap guy am i
right that's me oh okay
oh this is fun happening having a good
time oh [ __ ] closet turn up the light
and sit in the bed right so that's what
I had to do right you are not getting
like a little teddy bear or something I
can hug down here below
[Music]
honest book you mate come on turn on the
light clicking okay we're fine we're
fine but knit we're do that
no stop stop
this is scaring me no I mean I'm not
scared huh yeah what happened okay let's
try that again Jesus Christ I didn't
last long just like real life am i right
ha ha top of the mornin to you okay oh
[ __ ] it's Jeff let's just sit here and
chill
[Music]
she'll we're just telling everybody bad
net spreaded best game ever so scary
when they jump in my face so glad
there's more smashing I really feel like
we're not getting enough of those when I
wake up all the time my in the middle of
the night cold sweat more fat cakes
more fact we need more fans why are they
not more fast
oh [ __ ] dog you're not welcome here dog
[ __ ] that sound
how long have to keep them closed
alright we're fine who did that who said
that hello
I keep this on man thank you thank you
everybody I scared by the way Monday my
pipe I never get scared of anything okay
all right just turn up the lie am i
right there we go what you can't do
something what you go [ __ ] them Oh
God
all the creepiest part go back in your
room chicken boy I don't want your hair
anymore I don't care if you want my butt
that's right now let's turn on the light
of Guinness and my name again they ain't
scared
Thanks if [ __ ] down I'll fight you all
my McGregor axe I fought you all I'm
scared you just a little chicken dip dip
dip dip dip dip dip hey homina majest go
away
the immunities game okay hi okay all
right calm down
oh [ __ ] dog s customer you're not
welcome here
Oh Fred [ __ ] [ __ ] ground oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh don't spook we we call we call
sorry anyone else
it says turn under like the Millers
program to be honest
what is 2:00 a.m. okay that means have
four more hours
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] can you just let
me sleep for five [ __ ] who do that I
don't know that's ready sleep now what I
am asleep I'm so sleepy alone what the
[ __ ] was that what did i do then well
now that I don't I didn't as it's
[ __ ] it's pretty cool idea that
you're playing as a baby in a crib like
really vulnerable it's trying to protect
yourself there is a very many emergency
okay sound by commonly never mind then
hey buddy you want to [ __ ] you want to
smash let me smash come on come on come
on I show you my dear hahaha that was
good that was really good
Bonnie will attack you if you're up shut
the light and forget it sit down
I think I said this before but it's like
if someone runs up to you and goes like
book you will get scared the first time
most likely but if someone keeps doing
it it's just kind of annoying
and I think that's the problem with
these type of games they don't really
bring anything else it's all jump skip
which is also the genius of it because
that's one really people just one jump
okay I get it but it's still fun it's so
cool
I I'm really impressed by that this is a
fan-made game this is really [ __ ]
cool have you guys ever had like a
really creepy experience as a kid
because I remember I had one of the
freakiest things ever was like I was a
really young kid kind of remember how I
stopped and I swear I felt like a from
this distance I felt like a skeleton
approached me maybe I was too young to
really understand that it was a dream or
something like that but
it really it really left the scar on me
like I really remember it so clear what
I don't know what I have to do with
chica you want some chicken nuggets
chica come on we can chill man we can
share we can hang out I think what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] loser I think we're doing
okay this time what time is it - oh my
gosh oh this is getting creepy now I'm
not going to lie this is pretty cool
come on 2:00 a.m. come on okay we're
back at 2:00
oh [ __ ] my dick hole jeez I'm sorry
be gone that was creepy Jesus oh my god
gave me goosebumps oh [ __ ] yeah
it's like chill guy did I [ __ ] up I
think
[Music]
[ __ ] this is our tip like everything I
said go away
thank you Jesus what time is it
come on I gotta make this three is easy
pick
oh is it die here
shut up chica he's out there he's out
there he's out there it's gone okay
we're good we're good we're doing good
what time it's three three three come on
baby come on man come on man we can do
this man through um in the moaning okay
refined we'll wait forever 2000 chica
check out how many times I got to tell
you I didn't need the chicken nuggets
all right they will beat you thank you
my god what a [ __ ] come on man
give me four is that all you got
oh she do not welcome here son you know
they
there were fake chicken I promise I
swear to you Oh God
[Music]
how many are going to scare me calm down
oh this game is a little hard it's just
like Dark Souls no I can do this damn it
I know I can't I'm the best gamer of
life
that's goddamn right thank you thank you
look I'm being a good boy I'm sleeping
look at me sleep every month
[ __ ] that she can be like [ __ ] hey left
and then I can't compete get here I
can't turn on the light oh I think it's
probably better if I keep the lights on
for now she get hurt real bad you got to
do what you got to do okay
still just for tough gauge I can't close
the window right now Freddie pink you
wouldn't mind I like
I don't know what's happening I don't
think a mom in a very good condition
right now this is hard this is really
[ __ ] hard okay three and I think
we're doing pretty well this time I
can't I can't really tell my god this
game takes long to complete it's like
one [ __ ] up in your dead boy is intense
two of them come at the same time if you
like what do I do
Oh God look at that like what am i doing
I'm sleeping a black look I'm slam good
the door thank you
he'll laugh mine chica man how you doing
buddy you want to come here but what did
that down
she got [ __ ] off like I don't have time
it's for [ __ ] off chica
I'm trying his leg you're ugly you've
always been ugly you look bad in a
bikini [ __ ] me she's the head I don't
mean to be some mean okay but it's 4:00
in the morning I'm trying to sleep here
oh god [ __ ] this here
Freddy's at the window what do I do if
they come at the same [ __ ] time Fox
will never be able to kill you unless
you look at him look at it there -
there's two of them
[Music]
[ __ ] man it's so much happening I just
want to slap
I was I guess pretty sure for a while
okay that's moxie
[Music]
doing pretty good this time I think I
think we can do it I think I seriously
think you can hey Chico you want to see
these you're like what you're seeing
baby I guess not
if we can make it to five I'll be like
okay there's a chance that's the chance
we can do it click your channel ticket
chance the content can chance - oh [ __ ]
dog
[Music]
och Gigi I don't have time for you
you want some of the ass boy I spread
the magic for you guys [ __ ] pervert
I know you wanted it oh this is bad
[ __ ] at five at 5 at 5 at 5 at 5:00 it's
[ __ ] 5:00
oh [ __ ] you still here [ __ ] but [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up sleep what's happening why is
he not going away
okay hey [ __ ] you can't kill you if you
look at him [ __ ] up unless you look at
him unless you look at him
[ __ ] oh it's private five it's five come
on come on
[ __ ] [ __ ] chica foxy
[Music]
like what am I supposed to do BAM get up
get up
[ __ ] [ __ ] click on the line again
nothing a pen I okay I'm not dead
hey how you doing buddy worry about it
don't worry about it that's why we're
fine
we're totally fine then look I did it
guys look at that it's fine
I turn around he's going to be there so
I'm not going to do that what's
happening what does that [ __ ] god damn
it great one what
[ __ ] one more try
[ __ ] damn it it's so hard if the
place so goddamn long it's like 20
minutes every attempt 10-15 minutes 15
minutes every year ten [ __ ] last time
I'm going to [ __ ] do it okay I know I
can do it sure the screw is not like
that so this lamp is my respect for
women right now okay and I'm charging
this [ __ ] mind
come on I practiced at [ __ ] five
chief that's cry come on I've been so
respectful come on
[Music]
gotta [ __ ] away but [ __ ] up bunny I got
time for you [ __ ]
[Music]
Jake is here now [ __ ] off chica come on
is that all you got cruel justice
[ __ ] gusting what do you want [ __ ]
chick fast I like you [ __ ] yeah easy
not like don't so going hell yeah
so [ __ ] funny but it's really great
but if that's a fella named Frank yep
yep Jim Wow
that was so easy my god I want Hannah
like I'm a damn I got a bad man duty
duty [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh there's more ah look I do you
want me to do more I might do more in
the future
thank you sister Fester's and as always
sister fish